sometimes certain situations in life
have you wishing for a quick way out
waiting to have a meeting with your boss
heading into an important test or
getting ready to have an awkward
conversation with a romantic partner who
just texted that we need to talk all of
these can be pretty hard to deal with in
times like these it can be easy to want
to run away we feel a part of ourselves
saying that it would just be better to
just bail out as quickly as we can but
just because choosing to make an exit is
often the quickest way to avoid a
problem that doesn't always mean it's
the best solution especially when your
means of escape venture into the world
of the anomalous sometimes you have to
face things head on but if you are still
really in need of a quick way out then
scp-120 might just be what you're
looking for but don't say we didn't warn
you now hear us out yes we know that
it's a children's paddling pool you
might have even owned one yourself back
in the day when the warm summer months
came rolling around your younger self
would have begged your poor parents to
spend several minutes in the sun's
glaring heat breathlessly inflating a
pool just like it then filling it with
water from the garden hose all so that
you could put on your water wings have a
splash around for an hour or two then go
inside to dry off the result leaving the
water in that paddling pool to go
stagnant as it got left outside in the
summer sun filled with dirt leaves and
mosquito larvae while you decided that
air conditioning in super mario was a
better way to spend your time but
scp-120 as will likely come as no
surprise is no ordinary children's
paddling pool sure it might look like an
ordinary paddling pool at first pastel
pink in color only two and a half meters
in diameter and less than a meter tall
it's even made out of that same typical
flimsy plastic that needs to be inflated
with air to hold its shape you know the
kind that absorbed all the heat from the
sunlight while your younger self was out
there splashing around just waiting to
burn your skin at the slightest touch
but the first key difference between
scp-120 and the pool you had while you
were growing up is well this one is
indestructible despite being made from
common earth plastics
scp-120 cannot be damaged or destroyed
by any conventional means though the
material it is made from will still flex
when pressure is applied and is soft to
the touch it also possesses an anomalous
tensile strength in other words scp-120
cannot be ripped stretched or otherwise
destroyed like an ordinary paddling pool
can and the scp foundation would know
they've destroyed their own fair share
of paddling pools in the research labs
okay so scp-120 is an indestructible
child's paddling pool surely there has
to be more to it than that otherwise why
would it be such an important object to
the scp foundation well you're right
there's much more to it than that after
all they don't call it the teleporting
paddling pool for nothing within the
pool itself is a glowing substance
almost like a liquid but somehow unlike
any in existence at least in this
dimension what exactly do we mean by
that well this liquid doesn't behave in
quite the same way you would expect from
say water for example and its physical
properties don't align with the rules of
our universe let's say you fill your
ordinary paddling pool with water just
like you would have done on a hot summer
day as a kid now because of the
properties of the water you know you
could easily grab a drinking glass from
your kitchen cabinet and fill it up from
the pool no problem however the
substance within scp-120 does not obey
these same rules you simply cannot grab
a glass or other container and scoop up
some of this glowing liquid see what we
mean the liquid is only really a liquid
in name and can't be manipulated in the
same way that an ordinary liquid can
however it does share the appearance of
being a liquid with its surface rippling
and shimmering often as it moves
so put all that together and what is the
conclusion you get that this substance
definitely does not exist in our own
dimension instead it is from somewhere
else entirely by far the biggest
difference between scp-120 and any
ordinary pastel pink colored walmart
paddling pool is the property that the
foundation is most interested in in fact
this paddling pool is part of the oh so
rare category of scps that actually have
a practical use thanks to this anomalous
property human beings along with the
clothes that they're wearing and any
items they may be carrying will be
teleported to one of 11 different
locations should they fall into the
paddling pool to reiterate they don't
call it the teleporting paddling pool
for nothing there are some small
limitations to scp-120s teleportation
ability for one the weight of the
objects or loads being carried through
it by one person cannot exceed the
maximum threshold of just under 38 kilos
or almost 84 pounds there are also only
11 destinations that scp-120 can send
someone to and these can't be
pre-programmed or predetermined
beforehand any subjects stepping into
the pool must be conscious carrying
weight under the specified amount be
biologically a human being and can only
use the teleporting paddle pool one
person at a time meeting these
requirements means that the pool will
work as expected the only repercussion
of not meeting the aforementioned
criteria is simply that the pool will
not function any who have stepped into
the pool carrying too much weight for
example have merely reported that their
feet touch the surface beneath the
glowing liquid first encountered by the
scp foundation in september of 1992
scp-120 was found in california
following reports of children going
missing in the area there they
discovered the teleporting paddling pool
and brought it back to site 19 for
testing it is currently unknown how many
children went missing or if they were
ever recovered regardless remember how
we talked about making a quick exit at
the start of this video well that's
because the foundation's biggest
interest in scp-120 was to use it as a
means of rapid evacuation for their most
important group of people the overwatch
command also known as the o5 council
during a major emergency like a
containment breach the o5s would use the
paddling pool to escape to safety as you
may have gathered from how we've
described it scp-120 has the inert
ability to instantly relocate a person
from one place to another according to
the theories of the scp foundation's
researchers it likely does this by
allowing the subject to pass through one
or more dimensions alternate to our own
we've also mentioned that one of the
limits of scp-120 is that it can only
send someone to one of 11 different
places these are distinguished by the
liquid-like substance contained in
scp-120 undergoing a change of color by
sending disposable members of d-class
personnel carrying radio beacons through
the foundation has been able to compile
a list of these destinations and they
are as follows the first of these is the
pacific ocean denoted by a blue glow of
scp-120s liquid when traveling here
subjects are deposited about two meters
above the surface of the pacific since
this location was discovered during
testing a foundation vessel named the
scps demeter has been stationed at these
coordinates to the public this ship is
known instead as the uss nassau offering
under the cover story of being a simple
meteorological boat but why would the
foundation leave a boat here the current
position of this ship means that anyone
traveling to the pacific through the
teleporting paddling pool will appear in
the vessel's cargo hold in a crisis
important personnel could be sent to the
demeter and the boat could even be used
to hold less dangerous scp objects if
they could be sent through scp-120
of course teleporting oneself aboard a
boat might be a bit trickier say during
a storm if the demeter has moved too far
from its current position there's a
chance someone might end up teleporting
inside one of the ship's walls the next
location is greenland where scp-120 will
send someone when its liquid glows white
arriving here one will find themselves
in a facility that the foundation has
established on site the cover story for
this one is that this building is part
of an expansion of the oil industry what
members of the public are not privy to
is the true function of the facility the
foundation set up this site specifically
to perform the same function as their
ship the demeter the facility even has
an airstrip and a refueling station
there meaning any who use the paddling
pool to teleport to greenland can
further relocate themselves aboard a
foundation aircraft if necessary if the
liquid in scp-120 ever changes to become
a deep black in color it will then lead
to one of five possible points that are
all practically identical these
destinations are various earth moon
lagrange points in celestial mechanics a
lagrange point is the area near two
large bodies orbiting in space to put it
in simple terms in this case these are
points between the earth and the moon
where the gravitational forces of both
balance each other out this is what
makes these lagrange points such a good
location for satellites as the equal
forces make it easier for a satellite to
achieve the right path of orbit so
objects or people sent through scp-120
when the water blackens will end up at
either lagrange point one two 3 4 or 5.
these points are located all the way
around the earth and are directly
between the earth and the moon whenever
the ladder makes its orbit around the
former essentially jumping through the
teleporting paddling pool when it has
been dialed to one of these locations is
like taking a high dive into the cold
endless vacuum of space ending up lost
forever impossible to retrieve the scp
foundation plans to potentially use
these scp-120 destinations to dispose of
anomalous objects during a crisis as a
way to prevent them from falling into
the wrong hands now we mentioned that
scp-120s liquid will glow white when
it's linked to the destination in
greenland but the same also occurs when
it's dialed to the snow-capped mountains
of the himalayas this famous mountain
range in southern and eastern asia is
home to a number of planet earth's
tallest peaks most notably mount everest
the highest mountain in the world
resting at the border between nepal and
china unlike some of the other
destinations the foundation has made
little change to this one no boats or
bases for anyone to materialize into
safety have been designated to the area
instead there's just an eight meter hole
where the bodies of d-class test
subjects have been disposed of hidden
from view by a canopy only in extreme
cases would the o5 council ever want to
evacuate here should scp-120 display a
yellow glow then someone traveling
through it will arrive in the sahara
desert in africa the sahara is being
famous for being the largest hot desert
in the entire world only beaten in size
by the northern arctic and antarctic
deserts located here is a much smaller
foundation installation an outpost that
would most likely be ineffective for
housing anomalous objects but in an
evacuation could prove to be a useful
hiding place for important scp documents
or even for members of the overwatch
command if scp-120 produces a brown glow
in its liquid it will transport a
subject to the gobi desert a region in
northern china and southern mongolia
famous for its unique ecosystem here
much like the sahara location the
foundation has established an identical
small outpost however this one comes
with the threat of another anomaly
scp-4024 this is a saltwater spring that
is gradually expanding across the gobi
which much like the teleporting paddling
pool has the ability to displace people
and objects to an unknown location
finally should scp-120 ever emit a
subdued grey-colored glow traveling
through it would lead to an area in the
sea of reigns but that's not a sea on
earth
that's on the moon and it's not so much
a sea as it is a vast plane luckily if
you were to end up here the foundation
has already thought ahead and set up a
station on the lunar surface and it's
thought to be one of their safest so at
least if the teleporting paddling pool
sent you to the moon you would be able
to survive that's reassuring of course
the real problem is how do you get back
home that's a question for another day
just like we told you at the start of
the video sometimes it's better just to
face your problems head on because
certain escapes can lead to more
complications than you bargained for now
go check out minecraft world destroyer
scp-4335 a welt in the crucible and
scp-1594 miss j's wizkid schoolhouse for
more scps that put the strange into your
childhood joys